robert switlik you have a new book out
called house rules what's it all about
well it's about um the first year in
office of a freshman congressman and his
name is peter hoagland he's a democrat
from omaha nebraska
why did you choose mr hoagland
well um
really uh any freshman congressman would
have served our purposes
but
the publishers wanted to go with a
democrat since they're
supposedly running the show here
and congressman hoagland won his race uh
with i think a 3 000 vote victory margin
so we thought that would lend a little
drama to the narrative who are the
publishers villard books which is a
random house subsidiary and did they
come to you for this with this idea yeah
i was uh contacted by my agent and uh
she said well you know they're looking
for a washington writer you're a
washington writer aren't you and uh
so i
it was billed to me as
a look at the human side of uh life on
the hill and
it was the the idea was that a freshman
congressman is still closer to an
ordinary mortal than most people up here
so that to get in and perch on his
shoulder might give people an idea of
what it's like to
become a member of the washington
establishment how does that happen peter
hoagland of nebraska was first elected
what year
in 88 when did you first meet him i met
him in march of 89 wait a minute i'm
sorry in february of 89
and
i began to
i guess shadow him
in
early march and stayed
you know
i stayed fairly close uh
intermittently there were periods when i
would hang around the office quite often
and then
periods when i would draw back when
things up here calm down a bit what were
you doing
for a living before you started
following mr hogan well i was uh
freelance writing i
wrote several children's books
and you know the the odd article here
and there
but
never
never written much about politics before
and that was also the idea was to get
someone
to write this who was fairly new at uh
writing about politics let me ask you a
technical question uh when i read the
book i kept looking for a picture
somewhere peter hoagland and there is
none in the book what's the reason for
that
uh
i actually i had several pictures that i
wanted to put in the book and i wanted
there was one that i wanted to use on
the cover but if you know anything about
publishing the author's advice is the
last thing that they want and those
when they're facing those kind of
you know vital questions so they
they decided that they wanted this sort
of
capitol hill power kind of look you know
with the dome floating in the background
there so there was never any thought of
having a picture from the publisher's
standpoint um as far as
they told me that they were giving it
some thought i i think that was just to
make me feel better
all right describe peter hogan then
well he's
he's a very soft-spoken
conscientious guy he's
i think he tends to take a a kind of an
intellectual approach to
politics
that i think that was one of among his
main attractions to public life was
a real strong interest in issues
and in
working out um
plausible solutions to immense problems
this appeals to his type of guy where
was he born
he was born in omaha to uh a fairly
prominent local family
there was
the hoagland lumber company was
one of the bigger
presences in the local business
community and his uh on his mother's
side there was the carpenter paper
company so these are two
well-established uh institutions that he
was born amidst
what he's a democrat was his family and
his family was very solidly republican
was he ever republican he was most of uh
his early life and then that actually
came as a bit of a shock when he changed
cam was a bit of a shock to his family
he was
back home after having gone to law
school and lived and he lived in
washington as a public defender for a
few years
and then he uh married and went back
home and was working on the sly
on the campaign of for a democrat a
local democrat for i forget what kind of
office it was
and his his mother approached him one
day and said that she had heard a rumor
that he was a democrat and the way his
wife uh recalled this story to me it
sounded as if his mother said democrat
like someone might say drug addict
they weren't they were not too pleased
about that
where'd he go to school
he went to
stanford undergraduate and yale law
school
was he a top student
i i think he was a good student i don't
um
i don't remember uh specifically any
honors or anything like that but i
wouldn't be surprised at some point i
know whether i wrote it down or not in
the book you talked about
the number of
members of the house who have been to
harvard graduated also to yale
and then i think you said five of the
those have gone to both schools it was
like 50-something to harvard and
20-something
i wrote away to the uh
to all the schools i mentioned there and
got they have they're very proud of
their uh prestigious alumni and
yeah they're quite a few that come from
ivy league schools but anybody that's
hanging around capitol hill no that
knows that that's
just uh
not not only in congress but in the
bureaucracies there's there's just a
whole lot of people from ivy league
schools
so it really doesn't matter to you or to
the publisher that it was peter hogan it
could have been tom smith yeah well in
fact my first choice was um
a republican uh who whose name i guess
it wouldn't be fair to mention it would
be sort of
uh blindsiding him but
and they said that yeah that would be
kind of nice but you know it's kind of
like the picture on the cover idea they
just they had their own set
idea of what this book would be and they
thought a majority party person would be
much more revealing do you have any more
on how they actually selected peter
hoagland well i made the actual
selection uh and it was you know there
was not nothing very scientific about it
we just
i'm sure you're familiar with uh
uh congressional quarterly does this uh
roundup of the the elections and they
print these mug shots all across the
page of all the new members
and
we
i took a look at all those and i read
what limited information there was there
and
said well i think this guy looks pretty
good how much access did you have to him
well um
i had quite a bit of access to the
office i mean i i could basically come
in when i wanted to
i wasn't admitted to all meetings uh but
enough to get a good idea of how things
worked
and it's it's hard to to have much
access to things like caucuses and uh
a lot of there's a lot of members only
stuff going on in the hill so to
get an idea of what happened in there i
would just have to depend on him to
recreate certain scenes for me and you
know how these guys are very busy so
that's you know
there was often just no time to do that
i mean we'd be running down the hall
together and i'm saying so you know what
did it feel like in there what did he
you know what did this guy say to you
and he's got eight different
agendas going at once so that was a
challenge for a while what was the first
thing you noticed about a congressman a
freshman congressman that got your
attention you said you hadn't covered
much of congress well i just um i was
kind of amazed that anyone would want
this job for one thing i mean it's just
it's just really drudgery
maybe it was the particular year that he
came in
with the snl bailout landing on his desk
with a thud as soon as he got here i
mean it's just piles and piles of this
deadening regulatory jargon that you've
got to wade through and try to make some
sense out of it and you've got to mark
up in two weeks and you've got to be
able to vote with you know some degree
of intelligence on these
ridiculously huge issues it was just
there was a lot of pressure early on
besides that
you know he's got a big debt from his
campaign so he's got to raise a lot of
money and he's
got a
campaign coming up and he's
sure somebody's going to challenge him
if you only win by 3 000 votes so
there's a pressure every weekend to fly
back home and to
meet with you know all kinds of
different groups and to speak and to you
know just shuttle everywhere and do
everything at once
so it just doesn't look like a hell of a
lot of fun to me has he told you what he
thinks of this book
yeah he's not crazy about it
why
well he he says that it's uh cynical
and
he says that it's unfair
um
but i tend to think i mean i've had
various readings on that i've just read
a review in the washington monthly where
the gentleman writing it says it's
exactly the opposite he says that
the narrative exhibits
remarkable
fair-mindedness
so there's two opposite poles i mean i
think
i think it's fair and i try to present
both sides
on any given issue but i think that
the career of a freshman congressman is
such that
it's bound to look
a little
fishy if you look too closely
he's in his second term now that's right
how big did he win the first term
um
he won his
fir his first election by 3 000 votes
and the second in the second term he won
uh 58 of the vote he was his
landslide the district though has been
traditionally over the years republican
yes um well it's funny because there's
there's a democratic majority but
republicans consistently have won there
he was the first democrat to win in
quite some time
after you wrote the book
by the way what was the publication date
on it um
it just came out yesterday i think
so it's fresh yeah and when you had the
first copy did you go to him and say uh
mr congressman here's a copy of the book
on you well no it worked we had an
agreement that uh i would give him a
manuscript
uh before publication so that he could
review it and
tell me if he thought i made any errors
and you know in time for me to
make changes that i felt were
appropriate
and so that's what we did we sent him a
manuscript and he sent us back a few
comments were there corrections that he
tried to make that you went along with
there were some yeah and there were many
that i didn't what kind of things did he
want you to change that you didn't
that i didn't um
well for example um
he
in at one point in the book i in a in a
kind of breezy
section about his biography i was
talking about
what he had done in college and and
how he got started in politics
i
in passing mention
that he served in the military uh i
forget the years i think it was 62 and
63 and then i
said
wartime as he put later put it in a
campaign brochure
but he he served stateside he was never
in the army and it looked a little bit
like he was trying to
uh make it appear as if he was in combat
and there was a picture on the brochure
with him in battle fatigues next to a
couple of other guys and they had like a
tank behind them or something
and so he uh he asked me to take that
out he said that brochure didn't exist
and you know i had i had the brochure so
i had to disagree with him on that
on the question of his existence
is congressman peter hoagland in your
opinion an honest man
i think so uh
though i've had my doubts lately about
uh
his relationship to the facts but i
think
i think
he's feeling some pressure
the
congressmen get nervous when a negative
ad is aired or when you know even when a
a slightly negative story in the press
appears so i can imagine an entire book
would be the subject of you know
just paroxysms was this book written
about in omaha
yeah there was an article about it uh
just before christmas
and it basically it was basically uh he
said than i said you know
not for not very much the reason i ask
you that is that you write a lot about
the sensitivity of people in his office
to the press
into what's said in the omaha daily
newspaper
and i think that's typical uh especially
in an office where
there's
you know there's a real dog fight
expected in the next election
uh they want to keep their finger on the
pulse they actually had the newspaper
faxed to the office twice a day
good good chunks of it the morning
edition and the evening edition you
pointed out in your
book that that was expensive
well i'm sort of speculating on that it
seems like an expensive way to read the
paper
to get it faxed over the phone line but
then again you know you've got to wait i
guess
about a week to get it so if you really
need it
but you said congressman hoagland was
rather frugal
i did didn't i
i guess there was an inconsistency there
but you said things like if he had a
sandwich he'd take have to say yeah he
personally was i mean
that sort of ran through his whole uh
his whole method of operation he himself
was was personally very frugal and he
personally
didn't really enjoy
self-aggrandizement he didn't like
people calling him congressmen and he
didn't
like wearing you know those lapel pins
that members are walking around with
that identify them he didn't like
wearing that he thought that was sort of
bragging
but then again he knew that or he
believed anyway that uh
success in this game meant you know
keeping visible and so when it came time
to hire his staff
he didn't hire people that were
necessarily policy experts he hired
people with experience in getting free
publicity
and
people experienced in direct mail
so
that was the sort of tone of the office
uh
kind of how long were you around him
um
it was several months from march
uh pretty much to the end of the year
and i stopped back now and then
in 90 to tie up loose sands and when you
were there around him was it every day
um no it was uh as i say
for for certain periods if something was
was coming up if something was coming to
the floor or there were hearings on
something i would hang around intensely
for three or four days and then if
things died down i might back off and
not show up for a few days
there are a lot of things in the book
that we could talk about but a couple of
the
people from nebraska i want to ask you
about because there are incidents in his
congressional
life that you write about a fellow by
the name of larry king who was he and
what role did he play
well larry king was um
he ran a credit union back in omaha
which was uh
gained some notoriety when it was
discovered that
he was basically running it into the
ground it was thought that he was
this sort of model of a black
entrepreneur he
he was sort of wined and dined by the
republicans
as
kind of the kind of figure that would
lead blacks back into the party because
he was such a successful entrepreneur
and picking himself up by his bootstraps
sort of thing but uh
then it was found out that he had
basically robbed
i think it was
something like 30 million dollars from
this credit union in wild
bits of you know
cocaine using and
you know all manner of things that are
not looked upon favorably in omaha
and
that it was it was viewed then as kind
of a minor snl
uh debacle i mean it was sort of a
a little sideshow that reflected a lot
of the things that were going on in the
snls around the country and how did mr
hoagland relate to that well
when he got on the banking committee it
enabled him to
kind of take a more public posture on
this franklin affair which was getting a
lot of attention back in omaha it was it
was just
non-stop uh front page news and and six
o'clock news
so if the banking committee's
jurisdiction
included credit unions so to be on that
committee meant that
he would he would be suddenly a voice uh
in this entire affair
how'd he get on the banking committee in
the first place
well he
as i understand him i wasn't around then
but as i understand it
uh
he and his chief of staff uh
first of all visited with john mack who
at the time was uh
the uh chief of staff to the speaker who
at the time was jim wright these things
have all changed but
and
i don't i don't really know
what you say and how how you go about
you know convincing somebody that you
should be the one
to get the support in the end but
uh
dan glickman
who's
from
the neighboring state of kansas went in
there and
basically made the case that nebraska
was a banking center and that it
deserved a voice
and but what really put them over the
top was when the vote was tied
it looked like jim wright voted to put
him over the top
so i don't know that was that was all
kind of murky and vague and i really uh
i'm not sure how he got on there but
that
something in there may have had
something to do with it did he do
anything when he first came to congress
in 1989
to begin the process of getting to know
people in the party anything special
well
um
as far as
i i remember he used to go up to uh
he after he after he'd go to the floor
for a vote he'd actually go back to his
office
and read up on members that he'd seen or
shook shaking hands with in these
almanacs you know that are everywhere
politics in america or
there's another one i forget the name of
it he'd go up and he'd look at the
person's picture and read the little
biographical section and try to memorize
their name and it was you know that
that's that's sort of a job coming into
a place with 435 people
did he take you on the floor with him
no i couldn't do that i didn't have uh i
wasn't a staff member so i didn't have
any even you know most staff members
aren't allowed on the floor you need a
special sort of status
did you sit up in the gallery and look
down when he was on the floor yeah i i i
would stay in the in the press gallery
did you go back to the district with him
and did you travel with him when he
would go back there
i went back to the district twice and i
guess
and i did i traveled i went back with
him uh
when he was conducting town hall
meetings and
went to
quite a few of those
what was his staff like how big was his
staff what was the allowance allowed for
his office to pay for the staff
well the
the staff i
would say how big was it i think there
were probably
half a dozen people in the washington
office
the staff allotment the staff allowance
is something like 430 000 and
he uh most as i say he he didn't hire
anybody who was you know a bona fide
washington policy expert like like an
snl expert or something like that he
meant his his staff chief was his um
was a political consultant for the
democratic congressional campaign
committee immediately beforehand
his communications director had been his
campaign manager
and
the the office the the tone of the
office was definitely sort of a
continuation of a campaign feel
at least that's how i perceived it i'm
i'm sure that congressman hogan wouldn't
agree with that but
did you get some sense
of why he went into politics in the
first place
well
i i took him at his word uh you know he
said that he
he believed that politics
for him politics was like going into the
priesthood was for others he believed
that it was a way to give something back
and i see no reason to doubt that
talk about the last chapters about the
pink house
you talk about the difference between
living in omaha and washington what's
the difference in the price of homes
well
for what they spent here in washington i
guess 400 000
they tell me that you can buy a mansion
in nebraska for that i didn't price
homes in nebraska but it it sounds
reasonable to me but he was living in a
hundred thousand dollar home before he
moved here yeah it was it was a quite
nice neighborhood uh you know nice
little red brick house
and uh much bigger than the one they
ended up with here
and did they buy a particular i mean you
say the daughter wanted a
a pink house and they ended up living in
the pink house yeah that was very
strange the the
when it when it came
became obvious that they were going to
buy a house in washington his daughter
katie
out of nowhere i guess just said look
daddy i really love the color pink i
want a pink house and and you know very
he very gently told her well you know
that would be very nice but you don't
find many pink houses you know they're
not they're not very common
and
the only house that they wanted to live
in this one particular neighborhood in
chevy chase so that they could send the
kids to the somerset elementary school
which is a real hotshot uh elementary
school
so um
the only house that they could even
consider uh you know get nearer to
affording was this
you know stucco and brick monster which
was painted pink
uh it still is pink as i as i understand
it i may be wrong now did you say that
he lived worse here
in washington for four hundred thousand
dollars for his house than he did in
nebraska for a hundred thousand sure
looked like it i mean the there this was
a uh
a sort of a three bedroom uh i didn't
look like they were all and and
it was just a lot smaller and a lot more
cramped and the layout was
it was kind of funny did you let you in
his home here
yeah i went up there once
and what about his family where did he
meet his wife how long they've been
married um he met his wife in the uh
washington office of the public defender
uh i believe that she was
a secretary there at the time she
eventually went to law school too
children uh yeah i think they now have
five kids uh he's had one since he came
to washington
and what did he do before he got into
politics in
nebraska um
well
there wasn't there wasn't that much time
to do anything because he
he left uh
out of high school he went he went away
to school and
when he got back
uh i think he he fairly quickly got got
into politics uh this was after gail and
after working in washington as a public
defender
he went home and
began working immediately for campaigns
and he
organized a ballot initiative to
get sunshine laws passed in the
legislature which was very successful
so he pretty much leaped right in elect
he was elected to the unicameral
legislature the
only state in the union that has that
right in 1978
and uh that's and the whole the entire
unicameral legislature in nebraska i
think has uh 49 members and the house
banking committee has 51 members so
that's quite a culture shock there
and you say he spent his own money
to run for the house representatives
yeah well he he loaned his campaign
something like 250 000 it may have been
more
and
i thought it was kind of curious that
under the rules that currently govern
the system he can now uh or he did after
he was in office he could go to
pax and
raise money from them to retire the debt
to himself so basically the money was
coming straight to him and it was
entirely legal i don't you know i don't
mean to suggest there was anything
illegal but it just seemed kind of funny
to me you wrote that um
he couldn't raise money from his office
in the capitol
or in the rayburn building or where
where was his office located he was in
the long run longworth
looking back over the power plants right
uh but he had to go over to the
democratic congressional campaign
committee in a booth
yeah they have it's a very convenient
i've heard i've heard it described as an
ethics-free zone over there it's a
couple of blocks down from longworth
and
you can go in there
uh
it's it's a good place to rush over to
it it's easy to like run over there in
between votes or in between meetings and
put in 10 or 20 calls and
who's he call
well he calls
the one day i was over there he called
several
banking pacs massachusetts bankers
association i think was one of them and
it's all very routine it's kind of like
ordering towels from a catalog you'll go
he called up one
i think it was this banking pack and the
secretary said well congressman uh
would you fax this an invitation to your
fundraiser and would you spell your name
for me please
and then
basically it would just
the request would be pushed through kind
of like a subscription you know and did
he take you with him
to show you how it's done yes i went
with him and uh i did that once
and uh he
he didn't seem very eager to for me to
be there i i it's just one of those
things that
they're not too comfortable about i get
the sense did you ask him about being on
the banking committee
and then using banking packs in order to
pay off
his well campaign loan
he he i i did ask him about that i
didn't ask him about it specifically in
relation to his campaign loan frankly it
just didn't occur to me i was so i was
pretty boggled by this whole system and
i that connection didn't occur to me
much later
but
uh i did i did ask him uh why he called
banking pacs and not others and he said
that he didn't call pacs that didn't
have an interest in
the legislation before his committee
which seemed to me to be saying
you know you know
we only offer our merchandise to those
who want to buy it and i it sounded sort
of fishy i uh
but
congressman hogan and or let me ask you
a question is he any different than
anybody else in the community in other
words did you find anything special
about his way of operating no not what
the others do no no certainly not
everything he did was legal
oh absolutely absolutely
just um i guess what i'm saying is uh
it's a whole
it's morally questionable questionable i
think uh i don't i'm certainly not the
first person to think that
and
i think they question the morality of it
as much as anyone and i think it's
obvious yeah
i think it's obvious from the way they
shy away from
from doing this out in you know in the
open
this is what the book looks like it's
called house rules written by robert
swicklick and we're talking about
congressman peter hoagland a democrat
from omaha nebraska in his second term
but you followed him around
for a better part of the year of his
first term right where are you from
originally
i'm from pennsylvania originally and uh
grew up in upstate new york
where'd you go to school
george washington university here in
town right what'd you study uh i studied
political science what year did you
graduate
that's a very good i think that was
1978.
what'd you do after that
um after that i was
briefly
a teacher
and
then i became a freelance writer and
here i am
in this book you refer often
and i wrote it down on page 93 to a
festival of flattery
and if i as you describe what that is
i'll see if i can find a quote from you
i think i remember one well you i mean
you've seen enough uh
hearings on the hill to know that
it's just common
coin here for members of congress to
inject a lot of foam
into their remarks
the most fastidious most competent most
diligent most hardworking
gentleman from louisiana let me read
from page 154
and this is
on june the 15th congressman hoagland
quoting
um i appreciate our illustrious chairman
of the full banking committee yielding
that's henry gonzalez yielding time to
me and appreciate his gracious handling
of those complex issues in committee and
now on the floor
unquote hoagland enthused and he was
warming up
he goes on you go on to quote him
it is a great pleasure to serve the
gentleman from texas he has done the
nation and our congress proud with his
handling of this bill
right you refer to that often was that
irritating
i didn't find it irritating i found it
amusing
and i thought people also would find it
amusing
i don't know
why amusing well
uh ironic i guess it would be another
way to put it a couple of weeks later
after
uh
after mr hoagland uh
sort of basted his committee chairman in
that fashion he he basically turned on
him on the floor and voted against his
position on the bill
in a very public way
so uh
it just seems to be a lot of frosting
is it hard for a freshman member to vote
against his chairman
well it didn't seem hard for this one uh
he
he came to the decision to uh
after he got four amendments on the snl
bailout bill
one of which he was only able to get on
by literally begging his committee
chairman to uh let it go through
the same chairman gonzalez he um
he then decided for
other reasons not to vote for final
passage of the bill though the the
chairman had asked him to was the
chairman was basically uh
lobbying for that position so
um
but but on the walk over to the hill the
night of the vote the last thing that he
said was yeah i wonder if this is going
to offend chairman gonzalez and he
didn't seem to really take it give it
that much thought i don't know if he
if he really
sort of didn't think that through or if
he really
just didn't think that he would be
offended but he was as i understand it
furious at it and congressman gonzalez
yeah yeah
there is a and you correct me if i'm
wrong there is a gentleman from nebraska
by the name of yanni
right mikeyani mike yanny from omaha
nebraska right who is he
well he's um i guess you'd call him a
financier
he
he owns
a thing called america first corporation
which puts together packages of
investments for for people to join in on
and he acts as the sort of general
partner that manages the investments and
he uh put together groups to buy
a couple of savings and loans
and
at one point
the bailout bill
made it
it was sort of a complicated provision
but basically
it made one group of investors liable
for the losses of another group of
investors though they had virtually no
common links other than the fact that
yanni sat at the same table with both of
them
and one the one amendment that
congressman hogan was able to get in
with the help of his committee chairman
was benefiting
mike yanni back in omaha
if we can let's try to go through that
in detail
was mike yanni a democrat
no he was a republican and in fact
congressman hoagland went to him for
support
before the election and got nowhere but
then once he got into office
as so often happens
mike yanni decided or
through his pack i guess he controls a
pack back there to donate five thousand
dollars to the newly elected congressman
so things change and you you send your
money
with the winner
go back to what you said that
mike danny was in a position where he
he was involved in two different
snls he was the ch the controlling
partner in uh two different
uh
groups or consortia of investors
and
that link alone was enough according to
the original draft of the bailout bill
to make each consortia responsible
should the other lose money who came to
congressman hoagland first
to try to rectify the situation well i
believe it was i'm not sure on this but
i believe it was a
former congressman from omaha
john kavanagh who was
working for
or he was associated with a law firm
that
mikey annie did a lot of business with
john kavanagh the same congressman and
democrat who had quit congress
for what reason well he said he wanted
to spend a lot more time with his family
he quit at a fairly young age i can't
remember
uh i think he looked young i don't know
how old he was maybe 40 or something so
he brought the idea of a special
amendment to mr hogan right what did he
do with it then
well um
unlike a lot of offices
where the amendment might have gone
through the staff and bubbled up to the
congressman
uh and gotten pretty thoroughly
discussed along the way
congressman hoagland basically
looked it over and said yeah fine that's
that's good public policy and
he admitted that he also saw it as a way
to
build a bridge to the business community
back in omaha he didn't have much
support from them and mike yanni could
deliver that kind of support
so it looked good on the merits and it
looked good politically so he decided to
go with and he didn't bother consulting
anybody on his staff
and when when they found out about it
they were a couple of them were pretty
outraged
because it
this was clearly a case where if if you
wanted to get nasty you could easily say
that
here he is becoming a slave to special
interests and you know and taking
campaign money and introducing
amendments and what what does he come to
this freshman congressman and that's
exactly what uh happened when the wall
street journal
printed an editorial just bashing him it
landed on him with both feet
and said that he had
i think the title of it was
congressional crack
and basically accused uh congressman
hoagland and several other people of
not being able to resist the addiction
to special interest money and
introduce and just sort of
special favors
for those who deliver it how can an
editorial in the wall street journal
hurt somebody in omaha nebraska well
or did it
i don't know if it did but it certainly
scared him i mean the day after it
appeared i was in his office and he told
me that he couldn't sleep all night he
said he was tossing and turning and just
thinking about it all night that it
really got to him
i think
the fear is that
you know in the next election somebody's
going to take that out and take a
picture of it and put it in a video
machine
and make a you know a 30-second spot out
of it saying the wall street journal
says peter hoagland is addicted to
congressional crack or something like
that you know one of these brilliant
pieces
and they're very afraid of things like
that at some point had the omaha world
herald picked up on that editorial and
written a local story on it yeah they
did it they did a piece on it basically
um
he said he said thing
it wasn't
when congressman hogan went to them and
explained the merits of the annie
amendment i think they pretty much
dropped the story did the yani amendment
ever become law
yes
yes it it was in the final version of
the snl bill was it hard to keep it in
the final version
well when yeah that was another thing i
mean after he got beaten up by the wall
street journal on this amendment
uh
it came to the floor when the house
acted on the snl bill for the first time
and
this was a season when special interests
were sort of the main topic of
discussion and congressman leach
offered a motion to recommit the bill
just be it was just on the lip of final
pa or of preliminary passage in the
house and just before that he offered a
motion to recommit which is a very rare
motion it hardly ever succeeds
and it specified that
to recommit the bill to the banking
committee and tear out all the special
interest provisions and
it just sort of caught fire in the house
that night and i think it won by i mean
that's something you can't vote against
you know you can't start if you vote if
you vote against that you're saying well
yeah i like special interest legislation
so
that that lost big time and congressman
hogan ended up voting against his own
amendment that night
you wrote about congressman walter funk
roy
and a prayer that you were you there in
that room that day
no i wasn't oh wait um yes i think i was
i'm sorry and uh
what was it about the prayer that got
your attention well
there were
i think two or three
he the
congressman fondren opened up the one
session of the snl markups which is when
they decide what the final language uh
of the legislation is going to be and
that's that's pretty much where you can
you can easily if you're a special
interest you can lose 10 million dollars
if a sentence is changed uh here or
there so
people have
have their eyes open during that
proceedings and that's there's a large
temptation for
slipping favors into the bill that might
not be noticed very easily
and congressman fontroy
said a prayer to open the proceedings he
said it was the first time he'd done so
in 20 years on the committee
the to help us i i can't remember the
exact words but he basically said look
you know
god help us not to give in to our base
or impulses here
there's a what i'm looking at here's a
there's a headline that you do print
from the washington times it came as a
result of this prayer
that said members say grace before
digging in yeah well it was very ironic
because right after he said this prayer
boom boom you know right one after
another special interest amendments came
cropping up and were being voted on and
passing
so and and
congressman fontra i believe had one of
his own or voted for them in any case i
can't i can't remember you you're better
situated
to inform us on this point
let me ask you about what your reaction
was as you're going through this thing
you you had not spent much time coming
congress you told us earlier right
again what were you thinking as you
started seeing this process up close
well it just it seemed kind of funny to
me actually a lot of these things did
that
things just seemed to go on exactly as
you hear about i mean it was almost like
a caricature of
what you see in the news
people uh for instance introducing
amendments that they received in the
mail without hardly even reading you
know just because someone had given them
a certain amount of money or at least
presumably so
it didn't seem like there was much
creativity involved
in any case in
is the system honest
well
you liked what did you like what you saw
i i think
there is a lot of room for improvement
knowing what you know now would you get
into the game at any point how do you
mean as a politician yeah um no i don't
think i have the energy for it for one
uh i mean it just takes an incredible
amount of stamina to to even run for
office let alone serve there
and i think
i would be uh if i were ever to do it i
would be the type that would fizzle out
quickly i'd come in and i'd just start
shooting my mouth off and
probably never i'd never get anybody to
give me any
money to run again so
i think that's how that works there's
some odds and ends i want to ask you
about quote from your book late in the
afternoon of the last day of full
committee markups a five o'clock shadowy
mood settled over the room
while tiresome debates droned on members
eased back in their chairs some reading
papers or swilling beer
in the middle of a committee room
swelling beer yeah there was one guy who
was sitting back there drinking a beer
it was late and
it was it was really painful i didn't
blame him at all
you also say that mess you you found
during one of the markups that you
arrived at the door early in the morning
and outside the committee room i don't
know if i can say it correctly but it
looked like a bunch of um
people at a bon jovi concert
i don't have my quotes right but well
explain that i guess i'm sure you know
that
for years now
there's
been a rule in the house that uh as
often as not
hearings are open to the public and
there's a section reserved for the
public
and for a popular
um
well popular might not be the right word
but for a for a proceeding where there's
a lot of interest like the snl markup
lines form early on to get those seats
so
approaching the snl committee room on
days when these markups were happening
it was very strange to see these young
people teenagers or
very young people in like spandex tights
and t-shirts and sunglasses and it
looked for all the world like a bon jovi
concert
not like
henry gonzalez and the snl banking
committee
or the or the house banking committee
but what happened then if you hung
around long enough you'd see this
phalanx of limousines come pulling up
and
these
lobbyists come piling out and their
pinstripes and their gucci shoes and
they would go up and take the place of
the bike messengers which is what these
young people were and they had been all
been hired for anywhere from 10 to 30 an
hour to just sort of hold the places in
line
so that the public seats ended up
being
kind of like scalped
for uh the the lobbyists
who's gary
gary caruso was uh congressman hogan's
communications director press secretary
quote
gary is you writing this gary had seen
members in longworth
hallways give one another thumbs up
signs gleefully predicting they get the
money
later he saw some of the same members
denouncing the rays on the house floor
they're such hypocrites he said that's
what he said he said that to you right
you wrote that down i did why
um and what was he talking about
well he was talking about
the first time in 1989
that
the house
there was a movement in the house to try
and give itself a pay raise
and for a while it looked as if it
wouldn't even come to the floor for a
vote i guess you may recall that under
the procedure that existed at that time
if they didn't vote on it they would
have gotten it automatically but there
was such an outcry from the public that
they were forced to take a vote and of
course
at the time they felt a majority
overwhelming majority felt that
voting for it was not an option
but during that time
gary tells me that
he saw members when when it still seemed
like the pay raise was going to come
through he saw members
congratulations you know slapping each
other on the back saying yeah we're
going to get it this time and then he
saw those same people going down to the
floor demanding
a vote on this pay raise this outrageous
pay raise so that they could kill it and
he saw he he didn't quite admire that
attitude i i didn't happen to be there
so i'm just reporting what he told me
your words again throughout the day
tubes all over captain hill glow with
c-span's coverage of house and senate
floor proceedings
they certainly do but
let me continue but members with
schedules anything near as packed as
hoagland's seldom have time to sit back
and watch their staffs have even less
free time so sets are left to drone in
the background like video music pumping
legislative atmosphere to every corner
of congress
well i didn't
i didn't mean to suggest that nobody's
watching uh however i think the way it
works is it's it's going on in the
background and then you perk up when
when something interesting bubbles up on
the floor or in a in a hearing but it's
basically on non-stop as far as i could
see
do they have
we really haven't gone through this but
what's a day like for peter hoagland
well did you follow him often from start
defending uh enough
um
but
it often would start with an early
morning
issues group um
he would meet with
uh a healthcare
issues group and they would talk about
i guess legislation that was coming down
the pike in the long term and they would
sort of
have invite guest speakers in from the
administration or wherever and talk
about where things might be headed he
would he like to do things like that
and
then he might there might be a meeting
of the democratic caucus which would um
that that was kind of the
highlight of the day because that got to
be pretty raucous though i couldn't get
him to report verbatim
very often on that
and when the house was in session
generally uh
after the caucus if the house was in
session he would um
have his series of appointments to
attend to he was he had a pretty full
calendar of
either lobbyists or constituents or
officials from one place or another
coming in to talk to them you mentioned
that he's a very straight-laced type of
individual you also mentioned a couple
of times that he
drank soda water or whatever at some of
these receptions and one at a fundraiser
i think
his drink of choice was club soda
do you get any sense of how much alcohol
is consumed on capitol hill
i didn't travel probably because i was
traveling with congressman hoagland it
didn't seem to me like the hell of a lot
was consumed but
that could be very wrong i don't know
you start off your book and you talk
about thomas jefferson and alexander
hamilton
for a reason
and i'd like to have you
see that scene okay
well it seemed to me uh relevant
uh
especially since
there's been so much criticism of uh
washington and congress of late along
the lines of well you know nothing ever
gets done in in washington
and congress never seems to be able to
do anything
and it it seems clear from looking at
the history of the
adoption of the constitution that that's
exactly
how the framers intended for the
government to function or
they basically wanted it to run like a
jalopy they didn't want the hot
political winds to drive it in an
efficient
and fast-moving way they thought that it
would be healthier
that that it didn't
move too quickly and as a result you
have
a president and a senate and a house all
elected on basically different agendas
all colliding with one another and
all these
different points at which special
interests can apply their pressure to
block things or to
get things that they want
but it's very hard for the majority
the you know all the all the people out
there to co to come together in one
place for one program
who's your favorite thomas jefferson or
alexander hamilton
well you know you can certainly see i i
think the the blend of the two was uh
probably good for us back then
uh because
you know you know we didn't the the
nation didn't have any money we didn't
have any army
to be going around with this sort of
absolute democracy probably would have
lasted about five years
but i think now there's enough uh
you know there's just enough
communications media to get
the message out to people there's enough
there's enough basis for building a
fairly strong consensus on a lot of
issues that it might not be to might not
be so dangerous to have a more of a
parliamentary system
to where where
a majority
faction was encouraged to come together
right now it's it's very hard to form a
majority point of view in this country
because there are so many at different
outlets
you write on page 158 one way
politicians control the news agenda
is when both parties stop talking about
something
then the press often won't talk about it
either despite its vaunted
aggressiveness the press sometimes seems
to have a yellow streak it doesn't like
to get out front on issues it likes to
follow the leader
yes
well that was
i think that's that was particularly
true and in the snl
uh matter in 1988
it was i think pretty
pretty widely known among politicians in
washington that there was something
really rotten in the snls
and that
uh something just had to be done about
it
but
you really didn't hear very much even
though that was uh
an election year there was a
presidential race that year and there
was
congressional campaigns you you hardly
heard a peep about this snl issue even
though it was a massive problem and it
was bound to cost hundreds of billions
of dollars
and there was a reason for that and
congressman leach explained it to me he
said that basically
the democrats were
just as guilty as the republicans well
he i think he thought the democrats were
more guilty but we can leave that aside
and
that both parties basically decided to
keep quiet about it now when that
happens
reporters don't get their sources
to
come you know come out in the open and
they basically would have to take it
along
take it upon themselves to break it
and
that doesn't that doesn't happen as
often as you like a lot of the real big
stories that you get are the
result of leaks and
officials coming out with something do
you intend to do any more on this
subject
uh no
you're finished with congress with
congress yes
what's next for you
um
well i just finished writing a book for
adolescents about
tecumseh
the
famous shawnee warrior who led a
revolution a failed revolution
i guess all the folks out in the midwest
know him well
if you had this book to do over again
would you do it again
i think so
it was it was a learning experience
what would you say you learned
overall besides what we've talked about
um
i think i learned how um
just how boxed in uh members of congress
feel themselves to be
uh they i think they feel that there's
so much attention paid to the presidency
and to sound bites congress
doesn't mix with sound bites it's you
know they've got a
they need they need time to to get out
and let their
sort of their imagination wander and let
and get arguments out there that are
fairly complicated and
it just it doesn't happen so they're
often laboring in the shadows and
there's not much encouragement to come
out in the open with a constructive
program
do you think that an opponent and by the
way do you know whether mr hoagland has
an opponent
not this year i don't i don't know
but do you think an opponent would want
this book
as fodder against him oh i'm sure you
know they'll use anything
i'm i have no doubt
i think you'll try do you think his
office is worried about that oh i have
no doubt
but um
you know that's not to be avoided that's
that's going to happen
it's politics do you think if they had a
chance
to do this again would they let you in
the door
no i don't think so
why
well i think he feels now that it was a
mistake
it didn't come out the way he wanted it
to
um
but i guess you'd have to ask him
now based on your experience of seeing
congressman peter hoagland up close
if you lived in omaha and had the chance
to vote for him would you vote for him
um i don't know if i'm ready to
uh
you know make an endorsement one way or
another
i don't live in omaha so unfortunately i
don't have to worry about that making
that decision did you see anything that
would have would bother you besides what
you've written here i mean is it all in
the book i think so yeah i think
everything that's relevant is in there
our guest has been robert swicklick
this is what the book looks like it's
called house rules
it's about a freshman congressman
congressman peter hoagland a democrat of
omaha nebraska
and this book was written about his
first year in 1989. mr swiklik thank you
for joining us it's been a pleasure
brian thank you
is
um
uh
you